Making a movie can take years.
So it's no wonder Disney filmmakers often
break up the tedium by adding in-jokes and
Easter eggs into movies for their own entertainment.
Here's a look at some of these hidden Disney
moments almost no one notices.
More cowbell
Disney won critical accolades for its thoughtful
live-action adaptation of The Jungle Book,
which features Christopher Walken as the voice
of King Louie, a giant, fearsome ape.
"Call me Louie."
In one scene, man-cub Mowgli is deposited
in front of all the human treasures Louie
and his minions have accumulated.
Mowgli is intrigued by one item in particular,
and he picks it up and shakes it: a cowbell.
Unless you somehow missed the significance,
that's a clear reference to Walken's enormously
popular 2000 Saturday Night Live sketch, in
which he plays a music producer in the studio
making Blue Oyster Cult's "Don't Fear the
Reaper," and who persistently demands "more
cowbell!"
Looks like he finally got it.
"Guess what?
I got a fever, and the only prescription is
more cowbell."
Rudyard Kipling's Jungle Book shout-out
The Jungle Book movie is not only faithful
to the original book, it also gives it a subtle
nod.
Mowgli has two notable scars.
The one on the right of his chest forms a
lower-case "r," while one on his left shoulder
resembles a "k."
Those aren't accidents—RK are the initials
of Rudyard Kipling, who in 1900 wrote the
anthology of stories that inspired The Jungle
Book films.
Canine crossover
The "Twilight Bark" is a pivotal moment in
101 Dalmatians, in which every dog in London
is contacted for help in reclaiming all those
puppies kidnapped by Cruella De Vil.
Among the dogs who hear the call: Lady and
the Tramp from, well, Lady and the Tramp,
on a dark street, barely concealed in shadow.
Also in the scene, in separate cameos, are
Lady and the Tramp characters Jock the terrier
and Peg and Bull.
Tarzan's familiar teapot
Upon her arrival in the jungle, Miss Porter
has tea service laid out with a very nice
and very well-known china set.
Recognize it?
It's the exact same pattern sported by Mrs.
Potts and Chip from Beauty and the Beast.
It only appears on screen for a split second,
but it made enough of an impression to be
a real-life Easter egg as well.
At Tarzan's Treehouse in Disneyland, a replica
of the tea service sits on a table — and
it's movie accurate, down to the Beauty and
the Beast-inspired teapot and cups.
Big Hero 6 meets Frozen
Big Hero 6 was released in early 2014, right
on the heels of Disney's wildly popular Frozen.
Unsurprisingly, the movie is loaded with Frozen-inspired
bits.
For example, when Hiro and robot Baymax take
flight over the city, Olaf the snowman can
be spotted.
An aerial shot also shows off San Fransokyo's
bay and harbor, where a ship from Arendelle
is ported.
And when the hero crew makes a permanent headquarters
out of the wealthy Fred's stately home, the
robot Baymax tries out his weaponry and blows
away a statue: a stone rendering of the villainous
Prince Hans from Frozen.
Justice!
"Oh, Anna.
If only there was someone out there who loved
you."
What a jerk.
Princess party
Elsa's coronation attracts some pretty powerful
people from all over the realm — and beyond:
visible among the guests are Rapunzel and
Flynn Rider from Tangled.
It doesn't end there: a scan of a crowd scene
at the coronation reveals Tiana from The Princess
and the Frog got an invite, too.
The only one missing is Olaf, but that's probably
just as well.
"Whoa.
So this is heat.
I love it.
Oh, but don't touch it."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Disney in-joke is your favorite…